oui toujours là ok d'accord ok on va
essayer d'être spontané mais enfin bah
j'ai pas envie de trop provoc en fait
[Musique]
international la journée on se souvient
des femmes
au moins je l'espère encore nécessaires
à nos devoirs
ça ne devrait pas exister au moins tous
les jours devrait être la journée des
droits des femmes journée nationale
parmi tant d'autres journées nationales
j'ai l'impression qu'elle ne sert pas à
grand-chose lequel serait complètement
inutile la liberté d'être décelé aucune
égal mais en même temps différente des
hommes passait des droits il ya
l'application des droits restent être
respecté la vie des femmes et des petits
triple égalité salariale sera vous on
sera tous d'accord pour le dire qu'est
ce que la journée des droits des femmes
c'est encore vraiment à ça ou est-ce que
ça sert à promouvoir des opérations
marketing des opérations de
communication des rachats de morale pour
certains je suis pas certaine du coup de
l'utilité de la journée des droits des
femmes
en ce qui concerne l'égalité salariale
je sais pas si dans ma ville je vois un
de mes droits menacés
ce que je peux souhaiter à toutes les
femmes c'est qu'elle est à liberté de
réaliser leur potentiel
sur le chemin qui est qu'elles
choisissent elles j'espère qu'aucun des
droits ne sont sont menacés tête dans
d'autres pays
je crains mais laissez-moi part que ça
ne l'est pas en france
la vie encore le droit à l'intégrité du
corps des femmes et au respect de ce
corps des femmes
certains aujourd'hui voudraient que la
gestation pour autrui par exemple soit
quelque chose qui soit légalisé en
france n'est pas souhaitable
et pourtant aujourd'hui on nous le nous
le vend comme un progrès
[Musique]
moi le féminisme c'est justement le fait
que l'on doive pas dire c'est une femme
elle a été choisie parce que c'est une
femme au nom du féminisme
ça crée une autre un autre type de
discrimination et ça ça pose des
questions qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
c'est l'évolution des femmes normales je
suis étonné que femme mais subit si
longtemps sans se libérer et je pense
que maintenant c'est l'histoire ancienne
la pensée comme de près tous les êtres
humains à voir pour qu'on puisse avoir
les mêmes opportunités pour parler pour
ne pas rester dans le silence pour créer
pour vivre pour construire un monde
qu'ils soient assurés juste pour tous
autour tout pour moi la meilleure
définition du féminisme ça serait de
tendre et d'arriver vers
l'égalité avec les hommes il reste
beaucoup de travail c'est un vaste
chantier
pour moi en tant qu'artiste et
musicienne c'était émouvant de savoir
que par exemple une femme chef
d'orchestre et marne où il a dirigé le
cérémonie des oscars 2020 pour la
première fois je pense qu'il y à
beaucoup de femmes inconnues qui devrait
l'a marqué j'en ai rencontré au maroc
sont des femmes extraordinaires et
malheureusement inconnu aujourd'hui pour
moi c'est tous les groupes des femmes
qui se sont réunis dans le monde entier
en commençant par le chili qui se sont
mises ensemble pour dire stop
il faut que cette violence faite aux
femmes s'arrêtent et surtout je pense
beaucoup aux femmes de mon pays du
mexique qui est un des pays qui a le
plus des féministes et semoy le 9 mars
les toutes les femmes du pays vont faire
un arrêt pour dénoncer toutes les
injustices et le meurtre des femmes
la femme qui devrait marquer l'année
2020 ce serait adèle haenel avec sa
sortie fulgurante et avec raison je
trouve
la cérémonie des césar après j'aimerais
bien que le geste qu'elle a fait sa
sortie cette démonstration ne soit pas
complètement instrumentalisée il faut
encore par des gens qui cherchent à se
racheter une morale je voudrais pas de
cette cause de la soie récupérée